when you saw the Will Smith slap and all
that crap do you say to yourself thank
God
I don't host the Oscars because to me I
even found myself sitting there going
why isn't anyone coming out and helping
out Chris Rock the guy just got
assaulted on stage and you kind of want
to blame the host and say where are you
and you know if you had been the host
Jimmy they would have said that [ __ ]
Jimmy Kimmel he's a coward he didn't
come out he didn't wrestle oh I would
have went right out there there would
have been no I wouldn't even have waited
for somebody to say do you think do you
think absolutely absolutely I would have
went right out on on stage because
somebody needed to go out there at that
time and I think that was one of the the
the the drawbacks to having three hosts
is it wasn't clear who should go out
there and whose channels but when they
mixed up the envelopes and it nobody
knew what was supposed to happen I just
no one told me to go out on stage I said
I guess I better go up because I'm the
only one with a mic on you want to know
something I am now so [ __ ]
disappointed that you didn't host the
Oscars because what a great moment if
you would have been clear-headed enough
you would have had the presence to say
[ __ ] this and walked out and confronted
Will Smith in your mind how would you
have handled the dog what would you say
Hey will get in your [ __ ] seat and
get or get out of the what would you
have done you think I think I probably
would have started talking to Will Smith
I think that would you know who was
sitting there I think I would have
opened like what are you what are you
doing like what why what you you know
and I think that that would have been my
first step did you call Chris Rock at
all or speak to him uh after that
incident I spoke to him for about 90
minutes probably six or seven days after
it it happened you called him at home
and said hey no no I in person um I I
saw him in person after Saturday Night
Live I was in New York and I talked to
him at length about it and I really
don't I don't want to share what he told
me because I don't think it's my story
to to share and I think that he's gonna
but um he was surprised by it
foreign